tu le maire bonsoir bonsoir monsieur roy
ont bien entendu tout à l'heure vous
êtes vraiment furieux contre le
gouvernement fédéral
vous êtes un gouvernement qui prend au
sérieux les flintstone n'a pas à nous
donner des leçons d'environnement mais
est ce que ça ne serait pas plus simple
pour tout le monde que les études de
québec par exemple de mesures telles
soit dévoilée soient rendus publics
qu'on est tous les chiffres le tout
toutes les études se voit ses paniers
pas de game london ont depuis depuis
septembre 2014
environnement canada au tout le dossier
entre les mains on a demandé même la
semaine dernière avez vous d'autres
question avez-vous des besoins on est là
pour vous les donner on travaille de
cette façon-là au fur et à mesure et sa
suite façon administrative donc il n'ya
pas de bien là et là tout d'un coup vous
avez une conférence de presse de la
ministre environnement qu'on a vraiment
tendu mais qui encore c'est monsieur
lebel que nulle communiqué de presse qui
vient dire on va tenter de trouver
d'autres réponses aller chercher
ailleurs
ok je prends la balle au bond venez vous
asseoir avec nous au mois j'ai fait mes
devoirs on a même c'est une des raisons
pourquoi qu'à un moment donné je veux
reprendre des juges quelques jours
supplémentaires pour être sûr que je
comprends ce pas personne n'est content
de cette situation là est-ce qu'ils
avaient d'autres options est ce que
d'autres moyens il y en a pas d'autre
option donc tant du côté d'environnement
québec salue le travail de monsieur
heurtel de ce côté là
là tout le monde cause du succès d'opa
c'est de récupérer la réalité pour
protéger notre eau c'est ça la guerre
sur les études qui ont été faites à
québec parce qu'avant de vous dire oui
le ministre tél ils y ont fait des
études sur l'impact de déverser 8
milliards d'aud des égouts ces études là
est ce qu'elles sont rendus publics
si oui je n'ai pas vu mon kiné travail
qui se fait de ce côté là en terme de
transparence il n'y a pas de problème
mais juste vous rappeler qu' il ya des
experts qui ont parlé aussi quand vous
avez michel prévost qui est la
responsable de la chaire industrielle en
eau potable de la polytechnique qui est
dit que regarder oui c'est acceptable
oui c'est la seule option
vous avez des villes comme toronto il ya
10 milliards de rejet par année puis
qu'on le déclare même pauvre aller
jusqu'à 90 milliards de doses est
déversée dans les grands lacs
il ya des municipalités quand même pas
deux douzaines d'épuration nous là on
traite 99% ne trouve que il ya pas de
problème de transparence puis de donner
des documents
il ya quelqu'un qui joue dégaine
présentement
que sais tu fais de la politique sur le
dos des montréalais il y en a pas
d'impact au niveau du point d'eau
potable mais si on attend trop par
exemple environnement québec a dit que
là-bas période acceptable centre 15 au
20 octobre 15h été par la suite s'il ya
des bris le mène aux points d'eau sont
sont sont en danger
vous avez dit qu'à attendre ça mettra en
danger même les le système d'épuration
dit oui tout à fait bon tout à fait mais
je repose la question monsieur le maire
est ce que vous devriez pas parler aux
gens de québec d'hier rendez donc public
toutes les données pour que la
population est en noir sur blanc
l'impact de 8 milliards vous dites qu'il
ya des experts qui relativise ça on peut
tu vois ce nom ont peut-être factuel moi
j'ai pas de trouble ont peut-être
factuel là c'est pas dire on relativise
la personne qui relativise
est ce que c'est la meilleure option est
ce qu on est content que ça se fasse non
est ce que c'est la seule option de
façon responsable qui vont nous
permettre justement à cause de
l'obstination de l'eau de pouvoir
récupérer soeur puis par la suite c'est
ce qui peut avoir des impacts minimum
vous vous dites là la seule option vous
était la seule option n'a coûté pensez
vous que le symptôme models et puis
d'avoir des pétitions tout ça je prends
une décision qui est responsable
ce n'est pas de gaieté de coeur mais
c'est la seule alors je demande à ottawa
d'un dc parce qu'ils font pas leur
devoir la qui viennent le voir qu'ils
nous posent leurs questions qui nous
parce que nous depuis le début en
avez-vous qui n'ont pas des besoins qui
viennent nous voir on va s'asseoir avec
le gouvernement du québec je parlais aux
milliers sur terre il ya là pas de
problème à ce moment là ils vont être
obligés de faire la même chose qu'en
2003 et en 2007 c'était la même affaire
et environnement canada avait dit vous
faut y aller si le gouvernement fédéral
ne vous donne pas le flux vers monsieur
coderre est ce que vous allez allez
quand même vous allez procéder
contre l'avis du en son environnement
gardez moi lors on se reparlera moi ce
que je veux dans ses gardes et d'un
trois prochains jours mais une voix on
va s'asseoir ensemble tout de suite tout
seul moi je préfère la politique là j'ai
décidé de me présenter au fédéral c'est
une raison le chemin de montréal fait
que j'embarque pas dans un game ce que
je juge
moi je crois à la bonne foi des gens
venaient nous voir on va s'asseoir
ensemble on va le régler une fois pour
toutes que vous allez voir qu'il n'a pas
d'autre option qui parle aux experts et
vie télé les experts y en a pas d'autres
options les unités mobiles là puis de
france ex commune ce procès
les tutsis fournisseurs ça marche pas
c'est utile c'est impensable pour mettre
au pas de grillage parce que vous allez
voir des refoulements tout va bloquer
mais qu'elle n'a pas d'autre parce que
l'opposition à la suite ça va améliorer
ce que l'opposition vous dit en
terminant à vous monsieur le maire c'est
que ce fait huit ans qu'on savait que
l'autoroute bonaventure c'est un projet
on aurait pu penser avant c'est ce
gouvernement c'est cette opposition là
qui étaient contre le développement de
bonne aventure
deuxièmement garder c'est un peu farfelu
quand ils nous présentent des jours le
cherche une raison d'être
je comprends ce qu'ils perdent leur
monde mais pour moi lors ce qui est
important c'est de regarder de façon
factuelle avec les experts sont nos
répondu à toutes les questions
on le fait c'est la seule option c'est
pas juste une question de chute à neige
c'est une question aussi de s'assurer
qu'on enlève les supports de ce
collector qui peut provoquer des bruits
passe a été votée en 1990 et ça va nous
permettre d'être le plus efficace parce
qu'en conclusion vous serez trois jours
d'itt vous pour vous entendre avec le
fédéral puis les convainque garden voir
d'ici trois jours sans faim plaisir on
va s'asseoir ensemble gtech mes
fonctionnaires qui font un travail
colossal sont prêtes à donner tout ce
qu'il faut ils l'ont déjà depuis
septembre 2014 très bien qu'entre temps
on s'attend à une charte elle serait
bien qu'ils publient 6 qui rendent
publiques toutes ces études qui dit
avoir sur tel que le département de
l'environnement rang des choses des
choses publiques
moi je suis prête à vous donner ce que
vous avez besoin n'y a pas de problème
au bout de la ligne soyons factuel s'il
vous plaît puis il ya beaucoup de
gérants d'estrade
mais soyons factuel vous allez voir que
avec les expériences vous croyez pas
croyez experts on n'a plus une réaction
saine monsieur le maire que la
population 10 euros
une réaction saine vous le comprenez non
mais jusque là car je les ai fait mon
nom mais comme moi c'est que j'ai été
rappelé pendant deux jours mode moi j'ai
pas de problème avec la population une
réaction je suis d'accord avec ça mais
qu'on mette pas de l'huile sur le feu
des gens que ça tirait des points
politiques parce que le improvise by
pass d'un jour l'enac deviennent experts
on travaille des experts on comprend la
réalité du moment mais c'est la chose à
faire je connais remercie le plaisir
sera là c'est beaucoup